either way
hi james what's up
all right we'll get started uh first
question mark berman
hey james take us through the the tip by
robert coming in when you missed a free
throw and he came in there and got it
done
uh i'm gonna leave a play him and uh him
and pj communicated you know what they
were gonna do
you know on the offensive rebound
honestly like i didn't mean to miss
it you know like i wanted i intended to
make it it was just a perfect miss
um they did an unbelievable job of
moving uh the dallas bigs around and was
able to tip the ball in
christmas
hey james after not playing a game that
mattered for so long what was it like to
finally play a game that mattered and
have such an exciting game like you had
tonight
i felt good you know obviously we got a
lot of things to correct
you know we watch film tomorrow but i
think the overall intensity
over overall effort was there you know
dallas is a really good team especially
especially offensively
uh they created so many uh mismatched
mismatches and um
they got so many shooters on the floor
so they put your situation where you
have to help over help and then
that's when you knock shots down but we
did a really good job of just staying
with it
for the course of the game and give
ourselves a chance at the end and we
made some big shots
jonathan fagan
to hold dallas to 20 in the fourth
quarter and then come on
as strong in overtime as you guys did
how much was this win just about
fitness and endurance uh under the
circumstances
fitness legs conditioning um and the
will to win
you know we've in practice we get after
it you know so our legs
you know we're broke for it especially
we're smaller so we got to be built for
we got to make sure that
throughout the course of a four-quarter
game and in overtime uh like tonight
you know we're always ready and uh the
guys did an unbelievable job especially
in that fourth quarter
we were engaged we were talking at each
other's backs and we got some huge shots
when we needed them
thank you kelly kelly eco
james uh kind of talk about the spirit
of you guys being down
double digits and coming back you know
in overtime and for the fourth quarter
huge you know i think that's that's key
now we need to watch film and start
games like we did in that fourth quarter
i think we're down 11.
uh obviously it's a really good
offensive team but our just mindset you
know once our mindset is where it needs
to be
throughout the course of the game um you
know our defense would be really good
our offense is already good so
uh we just got to keep working at it and
these these seven games left we'll
we'll pick that up randy mcelvoy
hey james great game tonight man um
talk a little bit about covington if you
don't mind had this shot struggling a
little bit but he kept shooting
he was being encouraged to shoot and
knock down that big that big one for you
guys
that's what he's here for you know and
he worked on his shot every single day
you know that's one of the reasons
we're small is to be able to create
shots and open shots and he had a lot of
them tonight which aren't going to fall
all night but
uh we built confidence in our guys to be
able to shoot shots
whether it's the first quarter or
overtime and he had the confidence to
knock that shot down was a huge shock
for us to put
this up for so um jeff had a lot of open
shots when we had a lot of guys that
had a little bit a lot of open
opportunities that didn't go in but
we'll live with those shots
dave mcmenamin
hey james uh the entire nba had to wait
four plus months to play a game
uh you and russ had to wait a little bit
longer
coming to the bubble after other
players around the league then you go
out and combine to score 80 points the
most you've ever had
as teammates do you think
missing the game or or that time away
eat it in the production you guys had
today at all
i don't know if it helped us or hurt us
you know because that's time away from
our teammates
uh doing that you know chemistry after
four months
building that togetherness um but
tonight was a great start i think this
training camp for those first three
weeks we had a really good training camp
you know guys are getting after it
uh building our conditioning building
our communication and just happy to be
around each other so
um like i said tonight was a really good
start for us you know obviously
you know we came away with the win but
we got a lot of things to correct
uh for these seven games going to the
postseason
we'll take two more to mcmahon
hey james um as good as the mavs have
been offensive this year clutch offense
has has been their one big flaw
how aware of that uh were you guys
and could you sense kind of that there
was pressure building on them as you
guys
were able to hang around there uh down
the stretch our confidence defensively
was building especially in that fourth
quarter we were knocking down shots and
then started off with two big threes
and we kept getting stops and kept
chipping away chipping away in that
middle of that fourth quarter and
uh they gave us an opportunity you know
and even you know one minute ago i think
we were down
six points or seven uh cleveland hit a
big three in the corner but
we came down and kept pushing the tempo
kept fighting kept getting open shots
and
um at the end of the day we gave
ourselves a chance like i said so
we got to be better though it's not it's
not even close to where we want to be
but we're building in the right steps in
the right direction
and last one adam smallin
hey james as you guys are coming back in
that fourth quarter
could you feel them hit any sort of a
wall or could you feel their spirit drop
towards the end of that game as you're
coming back
uh we kind of felt it you know their
legs you know
we kept telling ourselves we're built
for it you know we're gonna play four
quarters
and we have the legs to be able to push
through uh mental toughness
you know and so that's kind of was our
minds to each individual that was on the
floor you know we kept saying push
ourselves push ourselves
uh you know we got to our spots
defensively we were active we got
stopped so we needed to
and that's going to be the thing you
know making sure that we we're built for
four quarters and even overtime if we
have to
to be able to you know compete and um
you know play well
thank you james thanks
yes sir all right we'll get started
we'll get started first question mark
berman
hey russ what did you think of uh
covering this tip in there off james has
missed the free throw with
a couple seconds left in the clock well
i thought it was great man it was big
obviously
tied the game um you know we stuck with
it
uh big play for us brian bairfield
uh russ could you talk about what you
all uh you know you and james
being the leaders what you all say to
keep this team you know in the game
after being
down those three quarters uh just stay
with it man you know it's gonna be
out of us trying to get ourselves back
into with this condition and shape
um stick with everybody stuck with it
there's some guys on the team made a lot
of shots tonight that they normally
would make
um so we stuck with and came out the way
kelly eco hey rose can you kind of just
talk about
the in the just overall there's the
spirit of the
team like coming back from 13 down to
trying to
win the game it shows a lot man
especially right now um every game
matters leading into the playoffs and
we're going to take advantage of it
jonathan fagan
jonathan yeah um to have been able to
make corrections defensively and get
stronger as the game went on at least in
the fourth quarter in overtime
uh what kind of thing is that to be able
to build on is these
if it is as these games go on um when
you see spurts like that of shows that
we're capable of
uh we just got to put together um start
to finish
um but we got time to do that and uh we
move in the right direction
thank you mcmahon
tim mcmahon russ uh you guys obviously
are a vet team the mavs are
uh especially their their top guys are
young how much of a factor is experience
when you get into situations
close game down the stretch it could be
could be a factor i just think that we
uh we stuck with it
um we wheeled our way that win we
wouldn't took the game
we let them they thought they had it and
we went and took it away
christy ricken russ after not being able
to play a game that mattered for so long
what was it like to come out there
and be able to play a game like that and
have it be so exciting and go to
overtime and y'all's first game back
it was great it was good experience um
felt like a playoff game honestly a lot
of guys on our team
um had great energy it was a good win
for us
dave mcmenamin hey russ
i both you and james have wanted to be
the mvp
obviously with that comes a lot of wins
and and crazy numbers
in both your guys cases but tonight you
combine for 80 points more points than
you've ever done as teammates before and
and both of you you know you yourself at
the coronavirus
and missed the start of training camp
here can you just
sum up what it's like to go through that
experience and then put up uh
a really strong night like tonight i
mean it's uh
it's tough you know honestly uh at least
for myself just
i had to be at home for about you know
18 19 days uh no working out and then
come here for a couple days and
try to get myself back going um took a
little time but i'm still getting there
um you know james did an amazing job
tonight of playing at his face which he
does
every single night and um i try to find
ways to pick my spots
um help my team and get in the painting
and make plays
for other guys and um you know
a little slow for me tonight but i'll
definitely be better moving forward and
uh we'll be better as a team
we'll take two more randy mcelvoy
hey russ can you just talk about what
house means to this lineup
he was out there starting gave you 20
points i think five or six rebounds i
mean he
provided a nice support for you guys man
it's huge especially with eric bendall
how's it a good job he stuck with it
especially in the second half made some
big shots and big plays
on both sides of the ball he's going to
be big force moving forward
and last one cody davis
hey russ congrats on the win um can you
talk about how much a win like this can
help this team moving forward
thank you man i think it's uh it's huge
for us it's a
a great um shows that we
have fight shows that we can close games
which is important
especially when it comes down to
playoffs and under two minutes games
decided mid odyssey between two and
three points in the show that we can
close the game is huge for our team
thank you russell yeah